my name is fatima zazile the founder of  ikista from kuwait where we face many  environmental  problems related to waste pollution the  frustration  and lack of information we are  collecting recyclables  from houses schools and businesses in  order to recycle them  i exchange a full recycle to get a tree  [Music]  the inspiration came from the tv show  hawata  by mr ahmed shigeri who  had an episode about pollution in  general  and he was talking about waste pollution  and how can we solve it  and fight it through recycling as a way  to cover this type of crimes what i wish  for is to move towards this solution  and to act for nature  [Music]  you